yesterday was media day for super bowl
55 again different than ever before no
opening night no gathering of reporters
plus whoever happens to get in to ask
all sorts of crazy questions of the
players etc but still plenty of players
and coaches talking yesterday plenty of
interesting information developed and
let's begin with
patrick mahomes the mvp of super bowl
54.
is he better as he embarks on super bowl
55. here he is from yesterday talking
about one way that his game is improved
i think every single year that you're in
the nfl you learn more and more
you get different looks especially with
our offense we get a lot of crazy looks
and crazy blitzes and stuff like that
you have to learn how to adjust and to
learn how to to go out there and make
and have successful plays and so
this year i felt super comfortable of
recognizing defenses recognizing blitzes
recognizing coverages and being able to
get us into the right play and get it
get a successful play going into
completion and so uh um it's definitely
something i'll continue to grow and
continue to learn but i feel like i'm at
a different way different level than i
even was last year
that's the scariest thing about patrick
mahomes is he continues to develop as a
player he's only been a starter for
three seasons at some point
his brain will essentially be a football
super computer that has seen everything
that can process information that can't
be fooled that will know exactly what
the defense is going to do before the
defense does it like tom brady
is after 20 years of playing quarterback
in the nfl and you get to that point
where you're in the sweet spot where you
still have the high-end physical skills
and you
have the high-end physical not physical
high-end brain power it comes together
there there's a point
six seven eight years down the line
where he'll be at an incredibly higher
level than he is right now chris
well most likely yeah but it's still
it's extremely high level already i mean
even for a guy that's this young you
know in his career that's what's scary
about the chiefs i mean you and i we've
talked about this a lot through the year
right mike i mean we went through that
phase early in the season where teams
were playing off coverage not letting
them make the big plays do anything like
that and they of course adjusted their
game plans accordingly to that to go
okay now we got to grow our offense in
the short passing game and do all those
type of things and that's makes mahomes
have to make quicker decisions as well
and the fact that they're in the shotgun
and teams are having to disguise and do
so many different things to try to
just lessen the advantage a little bit
with all the great talent the chiefs
have yeah i'm sure mahomes has seen
you know some more intricate
uh crazy defenses maybe than some other
young quarterbacks in football because
defenses do have to take chances from
time to time because they know man we
can't play this team straight up but
really that's where it's become amazing
and they're almost unstoppable that way
zone they got all the plays oh you you
get up close to them and play man-to-man
they can beat you deep oh now it's you
know off coverage mahomes will make a
quick decision on man-to-man and get the
ball out of his hands and that's where
he's special the the physical and mental
are are both awesome
end of the day there's only 11 guys on
the field there's only so much they can
do there's only so much that a
quarterback has to see before he has
seen at all they're not going to concoct
some brand new defense out of thin air
after 100 years of football i mean there
will be adjustments there will be
changes there will be things aimed at
attacking perceived weaknesses on the
chiefs offensive problem is where are
they with patrick mahomes and travis
kelsey and tyree kill where are the
weaknesses on the chief's offense this
week one of the weaknesses and we'll be
talking about that in a minute is the
absence of the starting tackles but
tyree kill is there he's part of the
overall package that the buccaneers will
be dealing with when he met with the
media yesterday
hill talked about his desire to get the
football in his hands and do some of the
things we saw him do against the bills
in the afc championship here's hill from
monday
so this is tyree keys to victory
yes let's go oh tyree keys the victory
one get tariq the ball
two get tariq the ball
three nah nah i'm not i'm not even gonna
say that i just run fast man even if
they double me i just run fast still you
know because that's
because if they double me and i'm
running fast that's going to clear
somebody else up
yeah and even if they double him and
he's running fast they're still going to
find ways to get the football to him
that's the thing
you think he can take away hill
if you do you got to deal with kelsey if
you think you can take away kelsey then
you got to deal with hill you look at
the numbers from the afc championship
the bills were unable to take away
either
and it was hill who had incredible
numbers against the buccaneers when they
decided not to double him in week 12. he
was on pace at one point peter king did
the math in football morning in america
he was on pace for almost a thousand
yards in the game based upon his
performance in the first quarter alone
so yeah tyree kill
incredible performer and it doesn't
matter how many guys you put on him if
they can't stay with him once he kicks
it into high gear it doesn't matter
no it doesn't matter and it's how they
use them and how they use the rest of
the pieces and pawns off of mahomes and
tyree kill that make it so special you
know that's another thing that you just
you look at them it's it's hill deep
let's aggressive passing and then you
got kelsey work in the middle of the
field and that's where mahomes is
special because he brings it all
together mike you know he's got this
great balance of oh wait you're playing
man-to-man you're not you can't do that
against us
i'm gonna be aggressive and now i'm
gonna throw some go routes and some
double moves oh now you're playing zone
hold on let me recalibrate my brain and
now
i gotta think don't be too aggressive
have the patience to work kelsey
underneath or in the middle of the field
for 12 yards and do those type of things
and to me that's where the offense has
gotten better and mahomes has been
amazing you know the tampa games the
perfect example of it really in a lot of
ways they played some coverages where
kansas city just went
we can't let you get away with this you
you can't play bump and run on tyree
kill so then they were aggressive and go
after him the game goes on tampa adjust
starts to play some zone and things like
that and mahomes and company have the
patience just like they did throughout
the year like we saw in the afc
championship game to just go okay
five yards here eight yards here no big
deal you know tyree kill catches a six
yard pass it'll become a 50-yard gain
and kelsey he catches an eight-yard pass
it becomes a 15-yard gain and that's
where
it's fun to watch because you just feel
like it doesn't matter what defensive
scheme you throw at them they're going
to find a way to start moving the ball
and making plays
with hill the speed is undeniable how
has he grown he's a route runner over
the years
oh well he he's he is a good route
runner i'm never going to sit here and
tell you it's great but he understands
how to use his speed to his advantage
and he could put his foot in the ground
of course and make a right hand turn at
a hundred miles per hour
and yeah it might not be the most
perfect route mechanics in the history
of the sport but it doesn't matter he
understands how to push leverage and do
things like that they're they're all
nuanced that's the one thing too is like
you know we brady we know he's all in
that's what's awesome about him
but kansas city and andy reid and brett
veach and company they've acquired a lot
of guys that they love football and i
think it like it shows you know on the
field on a weekly basis and they work on
their craft and you you see that in
their individual play
i i at some point this week i gotta go
back and watch all of the week 12 game
because i remember the buzz at halftime
mahomes had 359
passing yards in the first half of that
game he was on pace to obliterate the
single game record set by norm van
brocklen back in the early 1950s 554 i
think is the magic number i never can
remember that a lot of these records are
burned into your brain i think it's 5 54
but i always feel like i have to check
it's 550 something and i believe your
homes was at
3 5 9 and and the buccaneers were able
to slow it down a little bit in the
second half well considerably it kept
him from uh even getting to 500 but
uh
they made the mistake of not doubling
tyree kill and it'll be interesting to
see how they deal with hill how they
deal with kelsey and how they deal with
getting to mahomes that's the big
difference that's this time around
two tackles gone eric fisher mitchell
schwartz has been on ir it's going to be
mike remmers at left tackle and that was
news to jason pierre paul at least the
name not necessarily the body here's jpp
talking about the guy he's going to be
facing coming on sunday
yeah jason's wondering what your
thoughts are on mike remembers and
when you face a backup like that you
just go in expecting a bunch of more i
ain't even know who that was man a lot
to you but
this is a tackle that you're talking
about yeah i mean like i said i don't
uh i don't too much care about it you
know they got they got to figure that
out and i'm going to play some great
football this weekend
yeah
doesn't know who he is no and it's not
bulletin board material it wasn't a
gratuitous diss it was just like i don't
know yeah who i don't i you know i'm
just gonna go play i don't care put put
anybody out there go find anthony munoz
in his prime and put him out there i
don't care i'm gonna go play football
that's his attitude in between him and
shaq barrett
with both tackles gone
they're gonna be able to get to the
backfield but the question i still have
and this goes back to last year when it
was nick bosa and company chasing around
patrick mahomes if he continues to be
slippery and elusive it doesn't matter
we saw that one sack against the
dolphins where they tripped him up like
30 yards behind the line of scrimmage
that is a rarity usually he knows where
his body is in relation to the others
and how to get away from
the guys who are chasing him and uh
there it is sack percentage
9.9 went under pressure that's tops in
the nfl uh it's just it's hard to get
to
patrick mahomes um
and uh
the 49ers couldn't do it last year with
their great pass rush they couldn't do
it consistently if at all i can't
remember if they ever sacked him last
year but it wasn't the kind of
performance we thought we were going to
see from the 49ers pass rush and we'll
see if the buccaneers can do better but
they do have that advantage with a left
tackle that jason pierre paul didn't
know what his name is
well yeah and you know you know just
that's going to be that's going to let a
fire under the chiefs a little bit like
mike remembers they're not going to like
put it on a bulletin board but you know
he'll remember that you know especially
as they get into the game and maybe you
know it's been three quarters jpp hasn't
got a sack yet something like that he's
gonna remember that oh yeah you don't
know my name yet either way and it
wasn't meant disrespectful like jpp
saying i agree with you i think it's a
guy that just
he just worries about himself he watches
the film and he plays football he's not
sure who's starting or who got moved
around on their offensive line or
anything like that but mike this is the
key to the game i mean it really is you
know this is where you know i ask you
and and where's the advantage at the
offensive line as compared to last year
for the chiefs is definitely not as good
going into this super bowl game now this
defensive line for the bucks i don't
think is as good as that 49ers defensive
line but it's very good
and then there's the aspect of okay now
the secondary and yes there's talent in
that secondary for tampa but as we've
seen all year
you know they'll give up plates there's
holes in their zone you can beat them
man-to-man especially kansas city and
and tyree killing company and that's
where i look at it and
just go
okay compared to last year where do you
think the advantage is like you know
last year you said it was very even and
things like that going into this game
who are you giving the notch up in the
match up the offense of the defense here
in this one or how much are you giving
kansas city's offense the advantage in
the match up
well i i still think that with hill and
with kelsey and the ability to adapt and
patrick mahomes improving as a football
brain they'll factor in the reality that
they're not going to be able to take the
steam out of the pass rush so they'll
have to do things differently and
mahomes actually was sacked four times
last year in the super bowl and even
though they won the game
and they had that great final seven
minutes it's kind of easy to forget
because we focus on what ultimately
determined the outcome of the game it
wasn't easy sledding for the kansas city
chiefs until they found the gas pedal
with the deep throat of tyree kill with
seven minutes left it changed everything
in that moment it changed the perception
of the game it looked like the 49ers
were going to win easily and the chiefs
turned it around and won the thing going
away but there were 22 sacks of mahomes
this year he was sacked four times by
the saints one of the best defensive
lines they saw
all year there were five six games with
no sacks at all i just i i think that
that the buccaneers defense has gotten
better on the back end
since
getting shredded in the first half of
the game against the chiefs in week 12.
you've got young players who have
matured you got a lot of draft picks
over the past few years that are back
there playing corner and safety and i
think that makes a difference as well
because if you can just slow down tyree
kill and travis kelsey if you can keep
them from getting open too quickly
then maybe you have a chance
at getting home
and getting to patrick mahomes before he
finds that guy open it's look it's not
going to be easy
for anyone who would be facing the
chiefs on sunday but i feel like the
buccaneers defense just kind of gets
overlooked because it's all tom brady
and company and that they i think they
are better than they were week 12. uh
they couldn't be much worse than they
were in the first half
part of its scheme but i think
collectively you know it's half of a
season since then seven games they've
played since then they're going to
mature they're going to be better and i
think they're better for the experience
of having face mahomes and the chiefs
once already in the regular season
i think that's always an advantage the
fact that you get to see a team and get
used to their speed and their movements
and things like that the chief's
offensive line's not as good as it was
you know at that time even though it
wasn't great in that week 12 match up to
where i went oh man it's you know one of
the best old lies of football nothing
like that but it's gotten worse because
of injuries and having to deal with
things like that we've talked about a
lot like the last few weeks about
all the sprint outs and things like that
to see this is where mahomes is special
and this is where it's hard to get a
gauge for the game in a lot of ways you
know i i today will go back and watch
the film of the game because on
wednesday i do a deep dive into the into
the prior match up a little bit but i
just know off the top of my head you
know
one the chiefs were this close to
blowing them out and i'm winning by 30
points but also what's fascinating is
the bucks hung in there the chiefs blew
some opportunities right machole hardman
fumbling in the 10-yard line they missed
michael hardman wide open for an 80-yard
touchdown and it was only like a 15-yard
throw there were some opportunities
where you go oh the chiefs could have
won this game 40 to 10 and we could have
been they could have been done by early
fourth quarter but at the same time they
didn't the bucks hung around and had
chances to win the game that's what's
crazy about this matchup and then to add
to that mike what's crazy about mahomes
is we talk about past russ pastrus
pastures but his movement and how they
use him
almost negates the pass rush andy reed's
so smart with the sprint outs and all
those type of things too to where
i really think in a lot of ways we've
been talking about pass rush but the
more i think about it i just keep going
man this secondary in tampa is going to
have to play the game of their life and
todd bowles is going to have to get have
the game plan of his life because i just
don't think you could depend on the pass
rush getting there and getting to
mahomes you're going to have to cover or
confuse them a little bit and i don't
know if that's possible but
i think that's really going to be one of
the key matchups of the game like you
said that young secondary versus all
these weapons and how they have adjusted
and matured and i'm not sure about that
versus this group
the bucks had two sacks of mahomes in
that week 12 loss final score was 27-24
and you had noticed down the stretch i
remember you saying it multiple times
that t's offensive line wasn't as stout
as it had been and it was forcing
mahomes
to avoid the pressure with his legs and
we know he can do that that's one of the
things that is a given
for the chiefs he's one of the few
quarterbacks who when it all falls apart
he can run away from pressure extend the
play and make a second play
after the first one didn't work the way
it was scripted and there aren't many
guys who can craft that second play on
the fly mahomes and the guys he has down
the field who will adjust their routes
and find an open spot that's some of the
moments when mahomes makes his most
magic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports